نقلت صحيفه المونيتور عن مصدر سياسي في
الائتلاف الاسرائيلي الحاكم قوله ان قرار
نتنياهو عدم مناقشه مساله اليوم التالي في
مجلس الحرب نتيجه لابتزاز وتهديد من وزير
الماليه بيت سلايل سموتريتش ونقلت
المونيتور عن مصادر عسكريه ان نتنياهو في
مازق نتيجه تقويد المجهود الحربي بسبب
التوتر مع واشنطن وان الولايات المتحده
تتباطئ في توفير الذخيره والاسلحه التي
تحت تاجها اسرائيل ونقلت المونيتور عن
مصدر في الحزب الذي يقوده جانس ان نتنياهو
يخشى الانتقال الى المرحله الثالثه من هذه
الحرب وان صبرا جانس وايزن كوت عضوي مجلس
الحرب امام عدم الانتقال الى المرحله
الثالثه من الحرب بدا ينفد كما نقلت
الصحيفه عن مصدر مقرب من نتنياهو ان شيء
يخيف اكثر من استقاله جانس وايزن كوت لان
ذلك سيتركه بمفرده مع المتطرفين في
الحكومه
ه